before we go we have a quick pick from
my little yellow book and that's a list
of things that i love
and i want to share and you can also
check it out on our website because
i'll load it up with good stuff every
week and today
it's free rain sparkling water
that's right so many people are drinking
fizzy water these days
and i love this brand okay
it's flavored seltzer with really good
stuff
added they've got check this out tart
cherry and siberian ginseng for energy
oh you hear that i just opened it oh i
heard it
okay yeah beautiful it's very good i
don't want to mix it with something
later tonight i'm sure you can um
blood orange and ginger with ashwagandha
for
focus oshawa what
ross i'm laser into you i am so
ashwagandha
into you i can't talk i really taste the
ginger this is i love this so much
these are good blackberry and
passionflower for calm
okay let's chill out
oh girl no these are good you know what
these are unexpected flavors aren't they
beautiful
well and the good people at free reign
are giving away
sparkling waters to all of our vfs today
so cheers to that and
um i just love getting to share
recommendations and things that i
discover
in life along the way aren't we all here
if that was like my job credential
sharer yeah that's so fun that you can
just find things that you love and then
you can let everybody else know about it
how do i find your little yellow book
it's on our website
and i refresh it every week and um it's
just something i
i love social media in that i think i
fell in love with it not because i was
dying to put myself out there more i
don't think anyone needed more of me
but i loved that it was a platform for
talking about things that we were
discovering in life
yum i actually knew where i could find
it i just asked because i wanted them to
know
well i want to thank everyone for being
here today
and to my wonderful bud ross
well thank you for telling me about
bridger10 i'm going to be watching all
weekend long oh
get ready okay it woke her up let's see
what happens to me
[Music]